now these stations have identified
themselves it I think it's time for us
to identify each other Peter Ustinov
Shirley MacLaine we have been asked to
announce the winner of the award for the
special effects do you think we should
explain what special effects are well
Peter they are a little difficult and
complicated to explain maybe we'd better
demonstrate all right yes this is a
short love scene which is shot in the
studio without special effects darling
this madness simply can't go on but I
love you hmm I love you too then let's
madness continues good they're good this
is the same scene shot in the jungle
with special effects
darling this madness simply can't go on
but I love you
I love you too Lou
the net madness continues
and this is the same scene shaft with
special effects in London during the
Blitz darling
this madness simply can't go on ilove
you too
the nominees for the special effects are
Tom Howard visual effects for Tom Thumb
Arnold Valesky visual effects and Arnold
and Harold hum Brock sound effects for
torpedo run the winner Tom Thumb Tom
Howard
the award for mr. Tom hard is mr. George
pal